Mì bà thống ba, chủ tịch của ba ôngi Grandiès, cả nèo sân nhật là bà nè đã mở các cuộc đàn phát về Mỹ,
nhằm tìm kiếm giải pháp cho những mất đồng sống phương trong với cảnh đào quốc đăng đường
mắt khủng hãng tình tế và nắng lượng nghiêm trọng.
Pháp biểu trên chuyên nhá nước, ôngiès, cả nèo cho biết, các cuộc tiếp súc được tên hành thông qua
chúng rằng của tế và chú trị nghĩ sự việc của ba gió chính ông chỉ đào.
Hoài ra còn có sự tham gia của cửa chủ tịch Raume Castro và một số con chức cau.
Tuy nhiên, nhá lãnh đào quốc ba không điều gió thời gian, để điểm cũng như thành phần tham gia từ phía Mỹ.
Các cuộc đối thoại diện gia khí quốc ba đã chữ sự em gái càng lớn từ chính quyền tổng tổng mi đường năng trọng.
Nó biệt sau khi Washington cắt môn cùng rau từ bên nơi ra, đây là đối tắt năng lượng quan trọng nhất của là ha bà nà.
Theo biac sáng nèo trong và tháng qua không có bất kỳ lũ như liệu nào được nhồng khâu và quốc ba.
Khiên lối điện của gia chừng đến bất oàn và tình trọng mất điện cho gia rời sảy ra trên diện giống.
Nha lãnh đào quốc ba nhìn mạnh, các cuộc đàn phán mới chí, giá rõ nâu và chỉ có thể diện gia lâu ra in nhau hai bên tiền chỉ và giữa trên cơ sở tôn trọng hẹt không chỉ chỉ và chủ quyền của mỗi cơ ra.